Hello there, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
And we're the slow-mo guys.
As you can see today
I've got myself a drill, and a condom.
What we're going to do is fill the condom
full of water and food coloring,
attach it to a drill bit,
and then spin the drill up from up high.
Basically what's going to happen
is that the drill is going
to be spinning the condom.
I'll pop it,
the water inside will be spinning,
and centrifugal force will cause the water
to spin out flat into a disc
and as it falls,
the air will rise up through the water
making cool bubbles.
And I'm going to track
that with a Phantom.
Sound effects?
It's going to be like
And then
Good sound effects!
Yeah.
I like it.
Take that you'll need it.
Oh that is not a good sign.
That is not good.
You don't want to see that.
Too many of our videos involve condoms.
Just the right amount actually.
Is that enough?
No you have to fill it all the-
Oh!
Oh man this is hefty.
That's good.
It looks like a scientific,
it looks like a bloody flask of some sort.
Yeah.
Looks good!
Pop!
You alright?
Yeah just covered in blood.
That was crazy,
my god it looks like a fish,
like a starfish spreading out.
Does it?
Yeah
That's what we want.
Oh that already looks awesome.
There it goes.
Look at that!
That's wicked it turns
from a perfect globe
into a disc.
That's amazing.
That's the underneath of it.
Because it's slow motion, right,
it literally looks like its flat.
It's just a ball that goes flat like that.
For no reason,
you can't see that it spinning.
This is a unique set of skills.
I'm quite good at tying condoms to drills.
Alright we've got no damn crew
so I'm manning both the
phantoms for this one.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Oh!
What happened?
I was about to pop it,
and as I was literally going towards it
it just went poof.
I don't know if I got that.
Oh you got some bubbles there.
That's all good.
You see I didn't track it
because I wasn't ready.
I was waiting for your knife to come in.
Yeah
That was interesting it looks like urine.
Funnily enough.
Do it again? Urine?
Yeah, urine, yep.
Ahh!
What happened there?
Oh!
I went early because you jabbed it.
I didn't jab it.
You did
You jabbed it and it didn't go.
I was just scared it was going to go.
I didn't jab it.
Didn't you?
No.
Alright so I thought I'll jab it
and then I was like, "Oh! No!".
What are you doing?
I was like don't jab it, try not.
See I thought you got it there.
I didn't jab I didn't touch it.
You jabbed it, and it came away.
Yeah.
Confused me.
So you started going down already?
So I went down.
Well this is all happening
in a split second.
Then I thought, "Well it's got speed now,
now I'll jab it".
So now you're thinking, "I'll go for it".
Yeah.
Oh! And then it goes. Oh it's cool.
Oh man.
That looked wicked.
And now you're stabbing it.
Bit late now!
I stabbed the...
You stabbed a hole in the water.
Why would you do that?
That makes no sense!
It looks like a pee chandelier.
Yeah.
That looks amazing!
It looks like someone's bladder burst.
I love that!
Well I though that video was lovely.
It was pretty, wasn't it?
Yeah!
All the pee coming down.
Lots of urine.
It was nice to see the water disc out
as the balloon was spinning.
I think if it wasn't spinning
it would just come down in a glob
and the air would get under it that way.
Well, be sure to follow us on Twitter.
Buy a tee shirts.
Buy a shirt as you can see,
that one looks really nice.
Yep.
Trust me, I've seen it.
And subscribe to the channel,
because of slow-mo and stuff.
We love it.
What's the douchiest way you can speak?
Like the right way you're doing
but really douchy?
Right, okay.
Hang on.
Well, I'm just going
to tie this drill here.
Bit of tape, you know?
That's what I'm doing.
It's pretty good I mean,
It's not going to move,
don't worry about it.
I'm all over it,
I'm pretty good at this sort of thing.
The best part about that
was the face you made
before you started talking.
I'm a method actor.
Yeah you were like,
"Well here's what I'm doing, so, uh".
I wasn't Northern.
"Well here's what I'm doing".
"All right, so here's what I'm doing,
you puts it on the drill".